Hi, it's been a while. It's been a while
because we have basically been slaying
the sort of dragons that nobody knew
existed or they did know existed kept
behind closed doors. Uh, in short, we
wanted to build software that would
allow anybody around the world with a
basic computer and an internet
connection to participate in the mining
of the Gajimaru. The reason we wanted to
do that was pretty simple and
straightforward. uh whilst a real
blockchain or an actual blockchain that
actually works minting real money that
really works, it has to start somewhere.
You cannot simply click your heels
together all Dorothy and be in Kansas.
You have to build it. It has to grow. It
has to evolve to the point that you
believe that now the core product is
sufficiently
well coded, structured and um
>> usable.
>> Usable. Thank you. that it can provide
that root, the core underpinning of the
whole Gajimaru concept. Um, so to get
from where we were, we have an operating
blockchain that's live October 22nd to
where we intend to be, we have a a fully
operational base for creating a a global
economy
for the people, by the people,
delivering the original vision of
blockchain.
That's going to take a lot of time and
development.
In between those two points, you are
mining this chain to to keep it alive.
As you mine it, you get rewarded in
gajus. The issue becomes a distribution
question. What's the point of having
gajus if no one else does? There isn't.
Now, if you're a Silicon Valley venture
capitalist, obviously that's that's fine
because we'll just throw yet more money
into doing a rugpull.
But our position was we wanted to create
a real currency that was really used,
real money that was really used, not
just really worked. So
we set about this plan at at the
beginning of November to deliver
software that anybody could install on
any computer with the minimal
intervention and participate in mining
the Gajimaru and hopefully bring
hundreds of thousands maybe millions
maybe even tens of millions of people
into this before we complete the
development of the chain itself.
That was the plan.
We knew it was a pretty big dragon to
slay. We had no idea how big a dragon.
We thought it was Puff the magic dragon.
It turned out to be Smog. And with that,
I will pass across to the poor guys who
had the job of actually slaying those
dragons.
Uh
well, so yeah, we have a whole bunch of
different uh conflicting criteria that
we were trying to solve for. So this
particular phase mining plan uh was our
solution to it. And then we had to bring
people in who didn't necessarily know
much about blockchain. That's an
audience issue that we have which is the
crypto bros aren't really our audience.
It's small business owners are our
primary adopters and they're not crypto
experts. Um they're experts at all kinds
of other things but not crypto. So, our
software has to be able to be us use
useful to them uh but then also be
genuine and there's some you know
there's a security versus usability
trade-off and we have to try to smooth
that gap over as much as possible. um
that's required you know we started off
with
I won't get into details here but I mean
we started off with architecture a that
fell apart then we got rugpulled by like
at launch we got rugpulled by payment
providers that wound up having a
cascading impact on our technology
uh our our platforms that we' chosen
suddenly became inadequate. So it wasn't
just set up a web shop, integrate with
some payment providers, then you'll get
this going and then your backend where
all the hardcore crypto stuff is working
is going to happen. No, the blockchain
stuff that was okay, we already knew how
to do that. We do this web shop part, we
get rugpulled by payment providers. Now
this is no longer inadequate at all and
the task becomes also
just poop out a web shop like with you
know no dependencies uh by last week in
addition to other stuff. So which uh
Dimmitar is now dealing with some
trailing pieces of that while on the
product side I've been dealing with the
userf facing pieces of that and the
saving grace has actually been the
community that we attracted uh wound up
being absolutely fantastically helpful
and some of the best people that we've
dealt with are our early users which
thank goodness for that because that
could have gone way wrong but it went
very very well for us so we lucked out
with that community um in the back And
Ol has had lots of fun uh just kind of
with the task of hey we're going to do
this hive mining concept. Um hey just
poop out like a whole hive leading
concept and make everything work with
dividend writing contracts that tie it
all together on the blockchain.
>> You don't simply walk into Mordor. It's
a little bit like that but it's gone
well so far.
>> Yeah. despite all these um
weird peripheral problems that ended up
being massive problems. So I I think we
can say that they have validated our
core concepts. So we are even more
convinced now that what we're building
is sorely needed. But uh and and uh we
know that we're not the only ones being
rugpulled by payment operators. This is
it's playing out around us. We have the
famous uh
debater Michael Nolles in the US for
example who is has taken his fight with
Stripe public because apparently he his
monetization from his ex platform is not
working and they can't tell him why and
uh he's been discussing that with them
for quite a while. Apparently,
he was debanked, but it's very unclear
why. Uh, we have the gaming community.
>> Yes, that's part of it. The gaming
community is up at arms because
Steam has now entered into their terms
of service that games that
fall out of favor with Mastercard or
Visa, for example, are not allowed on
the market. And um
it's also unclear there is a policy for
the payment operators that anything that
damages their brand image is probably
not okay. So that that leaves quite a
big
>> uh
uncertainty for imagine
>> spending years developing a game and
then you're trying to launch it and
suddenly you can't sell it. Uh the
market is closed because well maybe it
was a little bit too spicy for whatever
sensibilities.
>> Yeah. But also not illegal.
>> And this is the thing is and Craig says
this very well in the longer form video
that the issue is that it's not about
making things illegal, it's about making
them impossible.
And
that really opposes completely to our
belief that the individual should have
the ability to make choices. They should
be bound by those choices. They should
be responsible for those choices, but
they should have the capacity to make
choices,
>> even
bad ones. Um,
I I for me lifting the lid on just how
archaic and lunatic asylum like the
payments industry was absolutely
validated everything we've ever said
about what we're going to do with gajus
gaju pay gaju wallets etc etc because
none of that stuff becomes remains
necessary and arguably it isn't
necessary it's just convenient for the
people who make all the money out of it.
Um,
but I think the thing for me that that's
remarkable about this is the work you
guys did. Not only were you uh slaying
much bigger dragons than we thought that
that we would have to deal with. You
were doing things for the first time,
not just for you, but globally. The very
first time that many of the things that
you guys did were done were by you guys.
there was no Reddit uh forum that you
could go to to say, "Hey, I have this
problem. How do I solve it?" The the
other part to this that I thought was
an absolute blessing were the people who
came in and bought into this
pre-release.
over 300 of them came in and bought into
this pre-release and substantially and
they were the guinea pigs for all of the
developments, all of the things that we
pushed and delivered to the market. And
actually
their feedback was
extraordinarily valuable because it
meant that we learned things now and we
made changes now. That means that this
can really scale. And when we talk about
getting to millions of people, it's not
an aspirational statement without any
substance. UL has been doing the work to
make sure that the blockchain itself,
the hive miners and so on can actually
handle this. Greg has been working on
getting the products into people's
hands. And Dimitar has been trying to
juggle all of these pieces at the same
time in every direction whilst at the
same time we've all got lives. Um
Dimitar had a a new baby arrive during
this period.
>> He took
no lessons from me on um prioritizing uh
time with the baby, although he he
probably handled it better than I did.
Um
there's been a lot of human challenges
around this too and I'm I'm
extraordinarily proud of these people uh
Craig Dimitar Ulf uh and the background
Peter Santosh Peter Harpending uh Jarvis
and then the community we have um Adam
Percy what a an incredible gift he was
arriving day one saying uh look I'm a
house builder you're going to have to
simplify this
>> to become becoming the best advocate we
could possibly imagine to have within
our community who's proactively rolling
up his sleeves getting stuck in to help
everybody who comes in the door. Um the
energy and the vitality that we've had
from the people who've come in, you
know, a lot of crypto projects talk
about community. What they actually mean
is we've assembled this group of idiots
that we're going to do a bagrop on and
if you give us money, Mr. Venture
capitalist, we can build a bigger pool
of idiots to do a bagrop on. No, this is
a real community of people who believed
in the vision of what we were trying to
do. That we wanted to restore the
economic sovereignty of humanity. We
wanted to create what blockchain was
always meant to be about which was to
create an economic an open resource
layer, an open economic resource layer
that could be the basis for an economy
for the people by the people.
They bought into that vision and they
suffered. They paid money to suffer with
us over the last 10 months as we got
from concept to yeah we can start to
sell this in March and from March to
date they've hung in with us. They've
given us the feedback we've needed and
they've remained positive. What a
phenomenal group of people. So I have to
say uh from sitting from my position
looking at all of this. Yes, we've been
very quiet. We're a small team. We've
had massive things to to deal with.
We've had rugpulls on payments. Um, and
we're getting there. By the end of
August, everything will be working as
intended. It'll be a very slick
operation, just like we believed it
could be when we started this in
November of last year.
And
hopefully you all hear our call. This is
an opportunity for everybody to reshape
our economic firmament. This is what
blockchain was supposed to be about in
the first place. About delivering an
actual blockchain that actually works,
minting real money that really works,
and getting millions of people to
participate, not just in its
establishment, but in its ongoing
operation.
And with that, thank you everybody.
We'll see you again soon. Bye-bye.